here with reaction to all of this fox
nation host lara logan and adam bowler
who has himself negotiated with the
taliban i noticed a tweet lara of you
earlier today saying could we stop
pretending the taliban isn't a terrorist
organization they did release all of
these terrorists that were in prison
uh when they immediately took power so
that game that
we need to stop pretending i agree with
you
yeah
one of the most absurd things um for us
to witness i mean i don't know i know
there are people sitting at home just
like me who are watching this and
thinking like how can they stand and lie
um on this scale it's just extraordinary
they know perfectly well that the
taliban and al-qaeda and isis the
distinctions between these groups are
just power struggles internal power
struggles some of it is part of
deception operations you know i mean if
you're designated like al qaeda is as a
terrorist organization what do you do
you move your people into say the
taliban because they're not designated
and you operate like that but when
general john campbell's forces uncovered
the largest al qaeda base in ever found
anywhere in the world in october 2015
where was it in southern afghanistan who
was there 30 square miles where the
taliban and al-qaeda were training
together were working together i mean
they're married into each other's
families for goodness sake and you know
you just had the acting president of
afghanistan the former vice president
abraham who under the afghan
constitution is now president now their
leader and he told me in an interview
not so long ago that when they pick up
these prisoners or when they pick them
up from the battlefield and interrogate
them they find that today they're isis
two weeks ago they were taliban two
years ago they were al-qaeda you know
and it's sort of an ongoing circle and
there isn't a counter-terrorism expert
anywhere in the world who will tell you
anything else with a straight face
yeah and adam you've had a chance to
negotiate with them uh clearly they are
terrorists now we have americans with a
very strong likelihood that by monday
that we're going to be leaving americans
behind enemy lines
which is why we brought the vice
president now acting president on to see
if there's any chance that we can
somehow
find these americans left behind and get
them transported to the north to safety
when we can extract them
um are they a terrorist organization and
why did joe biden not act as they were
taking over larger and larger portions
of the the country
going back to march april may and june
and july why would he not have moved up
any
exit withdrawal to a point when it was
safe when we controlled kabul
it's hard for me to explain sean i mean
at the end of the day first let me
comment this is what happens when you
have a terrorist organization where
there's no accountability you get
behavior like this and so when we pull
out with our tail between our legs
there's nothing to stop this kind of
behavior in releasing isis k prisoners i
was listening to the tv yesterday when
the taliban spokesman said there's no
proof that osama bin laden perpetrated 9
11
you know that kind of brazen talk it
tells you how they're feeling they're
feeling pretty good right now and that's
a real problem the second thing about
the date and monday is i don't think you
define a mission based on an arbitrary
date you define a mission based on an
outcome and the mission here is get
americans and our allies out under any
circumstances that's what the mission
should be not monday who cares about
monday
laura will give you the last word what
should happen from here what do you
foresee as of tuesday
well first of all the united states
government needs to recognize the afghan
president and our allies who are
fighting the united states also needs to
do what they should have done a long
time ago and declare the taliban a
foreign terrorist organization which
they are we also need to get
humanitarian supplies into the panchayat
valley to help these people and past
congress needs to act congress and
leaders on both sides of the aisle this
is a republican democrat problem because
american weakness is a problem for every
american they need to act to pass laws
to make it illegal for anyone and to
give assistance to the taliban because
they are a terrorist regime this is a
disaster and it's going to get worse i
pray to god i'm wrong i don't think i am
and i don't think laura or adam are
either you're right sean
i wish i wasn't i wish i wish i could
say i was wrong i really do